I'm going to show you this video and
really I this is completely not joking
and no sarcasm blah blah blah this is
extremely extremely disturbing we
debated whether we were going to show it
to you but I think this really gets the
essence of how backwards these people
are progressives do not care about
people they pretend to this is faux
virtue it's not real virtue if you want
to know the Fallout of these policies
where they let these crack addicts out
on the street and they let the criminals
out on the street and all of those
things you know what happens actually
unimaginable things this is video it's
how long is this maybe it's 20 seconds
what is it seven it's seven seconds so
you can just you can literally close
your eyes if you want but I think it's
worth to just really drive the point
home that they are not good people this
is video from San Francisco over the
weekend this is a crack addict homeless
woman who gave birth on the street seven
seconds seven seconds
[Music]
okay
guys this is third world type stuff and
it is going to continue to go in that
direction and that's what I'm talking
about about the blueprint and the
separation do you want that and do you
want that nationalized through Democrat
policies Biden Newsom whoever it might
be or do you want to separate from them
live in a place that is reflective of
your values and defend that place so I
think you know what my answer is
[Music]
foreign